I knew I wanted to live in New York it
was in my blood and Miami was too small
of a town for me so so I went to college
of philadelphia with with an eye towards
moving here when i graduated and studied
English so I fell into magazines as a
you know way to make a living sort of
biding my time for something else came
along and the magazine thing just worked
my first job was at Conde Nast Traveler
magazine I love travel I love the
magazine you know I did a good job there
so I so I worked my way up there there
for about seven years and there's as a
senior editor as the news editor then
joined a couple other travel magazines
and then with hotter back by conde nast
to head of concierge com about two years
ago
non-stop 24 hour energy and and the
ability to get the best of everything at
your fingertips a phone call away you
know everything from the best sushi to
the best theater to you know all the
cliches right now I just I just you know
I love the fact that at three o'clock in
the morning they're gonna be a traffic
jam of taxis and you know in people on
the street
the best way to manage a city for a
first time or it's actually not managed
it let it managed you a little bit just
get lost you know there aren't any
dangerous places in Manhattan anymore
with a few very rare exceptions that are
out in the hinterlands so you know if
you walk around you'll you'll see a lot
of things you wouldn't see if you stuck
to the you know to the main tourist zone
so you know get out of Times Square
first of all right and you know the
thing about Times Square is and I've
seen you working York Times Square so I
see people having these conversations or
they say well there's nothing to eat
around here it's all Applebee's and
mcdonalds and and garbage like that we
have back home and I want to say to them
if you walk just two blocks west so hit
ninth avenue and there's you know
restaurant after restaurant after
restaurant that's all great ethnic food
and you know all locally owned it says
there's so much fabric to New York that
lies outside what the tourists usually
do so I say just go run front for
explorer
I actually had the perfect weekend in
New York couple a couple years ago My
partner and I stayed at the Peninsula
Hotel for a weekend we had a gift
certificate great hotel right in midtown
so he kind of played Midtown tourists
who went to Central Park we walked up
and down fifth and up and down Madison
went to the Met and then we went to a
show i think was the Asia Society of
Yoko Ono's works and I'm not a biggie
Okolona fan I just thought what the hell
let's just see what this all about it
was actually kind of interesting and
then later that afternoon we were
stopped and had a drink at a cafe on
Madison Avenue named Walker yo como no
so it was sort of the perfect New York
experience right me is like you know get
the culture you know from the you know
from the viewers point of view and then
you also get to run into the people who
make the culture
well actually I have a country house up
in the Catskills so that's my personal
favorite escape but yeah there's a lot
going on just you know within a few
miles of New York that you can you know
to completely change your perspective on
the area so you know whether it's going
to the beach you know in New Jersey or
on our at a Long Island or you know just
heading up to the mountains you know you
can go to the Berkshire so it's only
about two hours away and you know it's
completely different scenery obviously
but you know does a different pace of
life and even out in you know northern
New Jersey you go to the delaware water
gap which is maybe you know two and half
hours west of the city and you know
stunning landscape and you know
replacing the concrete canyons with you
know natural canyons
you